another Brazen Lie from your president
take a look there's polling by the
Associated Press that shows that almost
70% of Americans including 40% of
Democrats believe that you acted either
illegally or unethically in regards to
your family's business interests can you
explain to the Americans uh to Americans
admit this impeachment inquiry why you
interacted with so many of your son and
brother's foreign business associates
I'm not going to comment that I did not
and it's just a bunch of Lies you didn't
interact
with Associates I did not there's
lies really no interaction with Hunter's
business partners well that's what he's
going to go with Joe Biden is lying
right to your face according to records
just released from the house Ways and
Means Committee Biden emailed with one
of Hunter's main business partners and
Associates the so-called moneyman a guy
by the name of Eric Sherwin a whopping
327 times including 54 emails just
between Joe and and Eric Joe's vice
president at the time most of those
emails occurred when Joe Biden again was
serving all these communications were
conducted with an alias email account
something you're not supposed to do in
order to prevent future Discovery and
like a court of law according to the
house Ways and Means Committee and Jason
Smith Sherwin was the architect of the
Biden family systems of shell
corporations they have identified dozens
of them used to distribute foreign funds
these were not real businesses as far as
James comr is concerned in 2018 that
text message remember Hunter Biden
allegedly crediting Sherwin for helping
him pay his father's quote bills quote
my dad has been using most lines on this
account which through the gracious
offerings of Eric Sherwin I have paid
for the past 11 years in other words
based on that text Hunter implicating
his own father received foreign money
from places like China and and Russia
and Romania and Ukraine and Kazakhstan
uh with the help of Eric Sherwin and
then pops used the funds to pay his
bills all while Joe and Eric emailed
back and forth hundreds of times but
Eric Sherwin is just one of the many uh
Hunter business partners that interacted
with as Tony balinsky called him the big
guy now this is a picture of Joe Biden
who just said he never met with he said
I never spoke with Hunter his uh my
brother or any anybody for that matter
about their foreign business dealings
see that picture there yeah that's
Hunter's Kazakhstan business partners
after a dinner at the ever so
prestigious Cafe Milano people from
Harvard know that uh location now here's
another picture of Joe with Hunter
Mexican partners and here's a picture of
Joe Biden golfing with Hunter's fellow
barisma board member Devon Archer then
Vice President Biden even wrote Archer a
letter quote I I hope I get to see you
again soon with Hunter I hope you
enjoyed the lunch thanks for coming PS
happy you guys are together Archer
testified that Joe Biden took dozens of
calls with Hunters foreign Associates
and business associates quote Biden was
put on the phone to bolster the brand
the Biden brand and it wasn't Hunter
Archer then testified that barisma
executive that's the big oil and gas
giant out of Ukraine that they demanded
that Hunter call DC to Lobby against
anti-corruption efforts in Ukraine
and of course Hunter obliged now Archer
also detailed yet another dinner at the
prestigious Cafe Milano if you went to
Harvard you know all about it with
Hunter's Russian backer this time the
dinner was with the former first lady of
Moscow her name Elena batarina and the
big guy Joe Biden himself that's not all
another Biden business associate Tony
balinski says he met twice with Joe
Biden ahead of an unusual business uh
partnership with our number one one
geopolitical foe right now which is
called China and in a 2017 WhatsApp
message you may recall Hunter reportedly
using his father to shake down his
Chinese business associates quote I am
sitting here with my father and would
like to understand why the commitment
was has not been fulfilled I will make
certain that between the man sitting
next to me and every person that he
knows and my ability to hold the grudge
that you will regret not following my
direction I am sitting here uh waiting
for the call with my father that would
be Joe Biden magically a few days later
oh $5 million was wired to a bank
account associated with Hunter Hunter
admitted he had no experience in energy
oil gas or coal in any way shape manner
of form so he's dealing with the number
one energy conglomerate in China and
getting millions and he's making
millions out of Ukraine with barisma now
Hunter Biden is now threatening to defy
a house subpoena it is unclear if he
will show up for his deposition or Joe's
brother will show up in the case of
Hunter December 13th if Hunter is a
no-show Jordan and comr they are
planning to initiate contemp proceedings
and the president's son could actually
face real jail time as a designated
sacrificial lamb as we was reported last
week it might be a risk that Hunter is
willing to take in order to save his
father but let's be clear about three
things one Joe Biden did in fact
interact with Hunters business
associates and he did it over and over
and over and over again two according to
Hunter Joe Biden financially benefited
from the foreign money distributed to
his family the Biden Brand number three
Joe Biden is now lying about it once
again he lied to you the American people
before as a candidate as a president and
including yesterday if Biden did nothing
wrong why would he be lying sadly this
is a familiar pattern with Joe when
faced with any adversity Joe Biden lies
and he lies over and over and over and
over again take a look Mr Vice President
how many times have you ever spoken to
your son about his overseas business
dealings I've never spoken to my son
about his overseas bus sounds to most
folks like a crisis well look it's way
down now we've now gotten control are
you committed to making sure that the
troops stay until every American who
wants to be out is out yes this day
30 years ago Nelson Mandela walked out
of prison and entered into discussions
about aarte I had the great honor of
meeting him I had the great honor of
being arrested with our un Ambassador on
the streets of suo trying to get to see
him on Robin's Island the various shots
that people are getting Now cover that
they're you're okay you're not going to
you're not going to get Co if you have
these vaccinations yeah and wages for
Working Families have gone up while
inflation is coming come down 65% be
crystal clear no one
making less than $400,000 a year will
pay a single additional pennying tax for
all these things that were in the in in
the billback better
plan now no one on earth believes those
blatant lies but many in the media mob
they're more than willing to ignore them
why because Joe Biden's a Democrat
instead of investigating Joe's apparent
corruption while some so-called
journalists in the media mob they would
rather bash James comr for daring to
hold Biden accountable watch you're
calling it an influence pedaling scheme
and you don't even know definitively
whether or not it's Al loone no you you
don't understand it's like you're
financially illiterate I I you look like
a smart guy on TV listen I'm a I I'm a
banker you know I've been involved in in
a bank board for for a long time the
money that the bidens paid Joe Biden
back with came from influence pedaling
when they made the deposits and then
wrote the check the same day they had
like a two ,000 balance I think one
account they were overdrawn in and they
B they deposited the same amount of
money they wrote to Joe Biden there's no
question I don't even think the being
paid back from a loan being paid back
from a loan I don't think there's any
statute that says being paid back from a
loan
regard a loan all right so yes it does
matter if you take money from a drug
dealer if you loan money to a drug
dealer and that drug dealer pays you
back Sir with money that he sold drugs
then you're complicit hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else